foreign
[Music]
you can hear the pain Sheila Grieves her
mother who passed away just hours after
she met David for the first time this is
my mom
and how it happened makes it even more
heartbreaking by the way I also want to
acknowledge the fact that this episode
might be a little triggering for some of
you it might bring up some painful
feelings and
that's okay
sometimes we don't allow ourselves to
feel our emotions because they seem
overwhelming or scary but the only way
to release them is to allow them to pass
through you and to come out instead of
pushing them down because you know that
works until
it doesn't but of course make sure you
always have the tools and support to do
that in a healthy way
foreign
now David who only has a limited amount
of time in the Philippines with Sheila
is confused on how to best move forward
calling it one of the most overwhelming
experiences of his life
[Music]
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia
some of y'all suspected it was Sheila's
mom who died
at the top of the episode we see Sheila
breaking down in tears as David tries to
console her
[Music]
he then goes on to explain that last
night after he met Sheila's family they
went to bed and when they woke up they
noticed something
horrible
oh my goodness I wonder why no one heard
the fall or that would have even made a
difference it's chilling because it's
the same stairs Sheila warned David
about last episode the moment she
introduced him to her mom
hey
palette
this is my mom
y'all saw he almost tripped coming up
look I personally choose to live life
with a belief that people die when it's
their time but this also opens your eyes
to how living in poverty can increase
your susceptibility to accidents like
this
[Music]
David says when he saw her mother was
dead he lost control and was in complete
shock imagine being in his shoes he was
already heartbroken to see the way
Sheila's been living that was new to him
he's never experienced an environment
like that before and on top of that he
stayed the night at her home and woke up
to her mother
deceased that's a lot a lot of emotions
to process in a 24-hour period and some
of us are sitting over here complaining
about everyday things like traffic slow
service or an annoying co-worker who
probably is annoying but my point is
that clearly it can always be worse I
also hope that Sheila doesn't start to
feel like her life is too much of a
burden for David I've seen some people
go down that road and end up pushing
love away when it's there to help them
today is my mother's week in the
Philippines
to stay
with about enforcement four hours after
that or it is considered bad luck
so I stay with my mother today my father
stay with the body tomorrow when they
slightly open the casket Sheila sees her
mom's face and breaks down
[Music]
thank you
I know some of y'all are over there
crying or at least tearing up I know I
was
David tells Sheila he's so sorry this
has happened to her you can tell he's
doing his best to comfort her
sweetheart so sorry for what happened
and I know strong people can get tired
of hearing this but
Oh Sheila is so strong
[Music]
she has to watch but she will drop you
off at the hotel first
it's good for both of us
he needs some rest and I want to be
alone
David says this is one of the most
overwhelming things he has ever
experienced and he senses this is a very
sad time for Sheila he knows it's a time
she needs to spend with her family
has something like this ever happened on
90 day
what are the odds you travel across the
world to meet your girlfriend for the
first time and after a few days of y'all
getting to know each other she loses her
mother who she lives with and y'all
found her dead together it's going to be
interesting to see if this brings them
closer or if it drives them apart time
will tell I'm so sorry you have to deal
with this sad situation
oh
Oh I thought I'll wait for you
I hope this experience as devastating as
it is
brings them closer
[Music]
I really feel
happy
that David he has to help me it's
comforting me every time you saw me I'm
crying and he respect me the
I want to be alone
fast forward to the day of Sheila's
mom's funeral there goes her dad right
there wow he had no clue in this moment
where he was smiling meeting David that
hours later his life would change
Forever This is as raw and personal As
It Gets
[Music]
I have been crying every day and nights
since my my mother said I am a
physically mentally
exhausted
Sheila opens up about the pain she's
feeling and her family and loved ones
say their final goodbyes to her mom I am
very sad
then my mom is gone I have no one to ask
about my problems
and calling my name I will miss her
foreign
[Music]
of her mother's expectations
based off Sheila's reaction to her
mother's death it's clear that her
mother loved her and that's all that
matters she got the opportunity to love
you Sheila
foreign
[Music]
later in the day Sheila and David head
back to the hotel where she will be
staying for the night David reveals that
Sheila doesn't want to stay at her house
anymore she doesn't want to be where her
mother died which
is Beyond understandable
Sheila can't even think about a kiss
right now meanwhile David says he's
feeling out of place
Sheila has a lot to deal with and the
last thing he wants to be is a burden on
her
[Applause]
if it is really supportive but I'm
worried I cannot give him the love that
he expects hmm Sheila said she's worried
she can't give him the love he expects
we've heard her mention expectations
twice now first about her mom
and now David I'm alright I cannot give
him the love that he expects Sheila you
are enough even when you can't give
somebody something she's worried about
what David expects from her during one
of the hardest times in her life when he
just wants to be there to support her
he's clearly not asking for a thing from
her and if he did we would all come for
him the episode ends with David and
Sheila heading to bed to get some much
needed rest and thank goodness David is
there because if he wasn't there would
be no hotel for her to go to she would
be staying at the home where her mother
passed that's a blessing
how y'all doing y'all okay I know this
was a lot by the way 90 day dedicated
the episode to Sheila's mother which I
thought was extremely thoughtful and you
all know we don't do the leaving on a
sad note business so that being said
let's talk about what's going down next
week because honey Tyree
that's all I'm gonna say
I'm worried about you going this trip is
kind of weird
last week the real Carmella told me
she'd be open to meeting do you think
she might have been good with this guy
possible
I don't know what to expect but meeting
her could bring me one step closer and
getting the closure that I need
so what do y'all think is going to walk
through that door and why is Tyree out
here trying to play Neve on Catfish
look at him he's a little too giddy to
be meeting up with a person who
potentially scammed him I told y'all I
think tyrae fell in love with Carmella's
pictures he wants to see that woman in
person all right 90 day fans fam take
care of yourself make sure you stick
with E.T because we are covering it all
I will see you next time
[Music]